[Music]  now to a couple going very strong on  Twitter Blake Shelton went full-blown  fanboy for just a girl named Gwen in  Vegas tweeting quote so far Gwen Stefani  has performed three shows in Las Vegas I  have been to three hashtag stalker  he's like my besties though of course  he's seen everything  on opening night Lakes that front and  center with Gwen's four-year-old son  Apollo on his lap I asked her about that  sweet moment backstage what has it been  like to see that blend of the family  obviously like if you think about the  show what I was trying to say like in a  huge kind of love note kind of way is  like just how amazing life can be  there's always a rainbow  [Music]